Democrats pull a horrendous last-minute
dirty trick on Brett Kavanaugh we review
the results of last night's primary
elections in New York and we'll check
the mailbag i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
all right we've a lot to get to today a
lot of breaking news happening and we
will break down everything that happened
in New York last night but first let's
talk about your safety in security I am
somebody obsessed with safety in
security and that is why I use ring.com
at my home ring is the video doorbell
company that allows you to see and speak
to anyone when they come to your door
and they've actually sent us actual
footage of ring busting crooks in the
act this one is just weird and creepy
here's what it sounds like hey sorry
we're in the middle of dinner can I help
you yes how are you good how are you
good seen you in a while no I don't know
who you are I'm Justin I met you long
time ago god bless it turns out that she
did not know Justin when he was younger
and in fact Justin might have just been
a creepy guy trying to break and we
don't know anything about Justin other
than it's a good thing this lady had
ring because if she hadn't then she met
up in that front door and things could
have gone very very differently a lot
happens at your front door and that's
why you need ring and rings flood like
cam they have a spotlight cam as well
they let you bring a building ring up
security around your entire property
stop crime before it happens help make
your neighborhood safer with rings hey
up to one hundred and fifty bucks on a
ring of security kit at ring comm slash
Ben that's ring.com / Ben again one
hundred and fifty bucks off when you go
to ring calm / Ben go check it out right
now
ring calm / Ben for that special deal
alright so the breaking news today is
that poem Anna Ford has apparently cut a
deal with the federal government with
the Muller investigation we don't know
what that deal encompasses we know that
Paula that poem Anna fort had already
been convicted on several felony counts
related to bank and tax fraud charges
and then he was to move on to a second
trial and he pled guilty in that trial
to avoid a a longer sentence apparently
the according to the New York Times the
negotiations over a plea deal related to
a separate set of seven charges
encompassing conspiracy obstruction of
justice money-laundering false
statements and violations of a lobbying
disclosure law it's not clear exactly
what manna fort might plead guilty to
apparently he's pleading guilty to a
bunch of charges having to do with
failing to register
as a foreign agent of the Ukrainian
government back when a named Yanukovych
was was running the country in any case
man affords trial on the second set of
charges was scheduled to get underway on
Monday but now he has pled guilty he's
going to turn over apparently an
enormous amounts of property the federal
government what is more important
because who cares about Paul Manafort
what's more important here is that Paul
Manafort is apparently working under
cooperation agreement with the Muller
investigation which means that
presumably he is flipping maybe on
President Trump and this is the part
where it starts to get real dicey for
the Trump administration because nobody
actually knows what man affort knows
nobody knows exactly what man affort was
doing now again there's no evidence
that's actually been shown that mana
fort was actively cooperating with the
russian government on behalf of Trump
Trump could still say listen I just
hired this guy manna for because this
guy manna Ford has long-standing
high-level RNC ties going back
legitimately years years I mean ties to
top members of RNC finance ties to top
political members of the RNC going back
election cycles I mean several election
cycles and Trump could just say listen I
was looking for a campaign manager there
wasn't a professional available the RNC
suggested that I pick up manna for it
because they knew him I picked him up
and whatever he did on the side that's
his business but that doesn't mean that
I personally knew anything the problem
is that Trump has made kid claims that
the Trump campaign had nothing to do
with Russia if it turns out that man
afford as his campaign manager was
messing about with Russia then that
could lead to some pretty severe
consequences according to ABC the deal
is expected to be announced in court
Friday it remains unclear whether Manta
Ford has agreed to cooperate with
prosecutors were simply conceding to a
guilty plea and now appears that he is
indeed cooperating with prosecutors we
don't actually know again what's the
information that he's going to turn over
to prosecutors what exactly are they
getting in return for a reduced sentence
of some sort we don't know the answer to
that and we're gonna have to wait for
the answer to that but it's not good
news for President Trump obviously
president Trump you remember was
tweeting incessantly after the Paul
Manafort convictions a couple of weeks
ago which came out on the same day that
Michael Cohen pled guilty and said that
he was cooperating with federal
prosecutors do you recall that president
from tweeted out how much he loved Man
afford for not flipping on him now it is
now it's getting real ugly now it's
really ugly so man
has indeed agreed to cooperate with the
special counsel in the Russia probe on
July 31st mana forts attorney had told
CBS there was no chance his client would
cooperate with the special counsel to
avoid his first trial but now he is
apparently going to have to cooperate to
avoid the second trial so this could be
very ugly for the Trump campaign the
Trump administration we're going to have
to see what this actually means
everybody is jumping to the conclusion
that this is the end of Trump you know
again unless there is something deeply
unless there is something I think deeply
indicted and convicting a president
Trump himself it's gonna be very
difficult to make the claim that
President Trump was personally approving
any sort of Putin manipulation of the
election but we'll have to see the
evidence that mana 4 provides because
after all could be and Manta for again
does haven't he does have an incentive I
would say to spill as much of his guts
as he possibly can on the president or
to theoretically make things up in order
to avoid the consequences of his own
corruption apparently going back years
but the fact that mana fort is flipping
his bad news for president Rumple
meanwhile the Democrats are trying to
play every dirty trick they can with
regard to Brett Kavanaugh yesterday saw
the dirtiest trick of all this was
Dianne Feinstein's the senior Democrat
on the Senate Judiciary Committee she
refer to information involving judge
Brett Kavanaugh president Trump's
nominee to the Supreme Court to federal
investigators on Thursday but the
senator declined to make public what
exactly the matter involved two
officials familiar with the matter say
the incident involved possible sexual
misconduct between judge Kavanaugh and a
woman when they were both in high school
so now we're gonna go back 35 years to
try and find something that Brett
Kavanaugh allegedly did wrong hey Dianne
Feinstein's announcement yesterday was
just perverse because here's what she
announced quote I have received
information from an individual
concerning the nomination of Brett
Kavanaugh to the Supreme Court that
individual strongly requested
confidentiality declined to come forward
oppress the matter further and I have
honored that decision I have however
referred the matter to federal
investigative authorities so in other
words somebody came with information I'm
not gonna tell you what the information
is I'm not gonna tell you where it came
from
I've referred it to federal authorities
so it could be anything it could be the
worst thing you could possibly imagine
or it could be the Bret cabin always
mean to someone back in high school but
I'm not gonna say so and this is where
you start to look at this stuff and say
yeah this is pretty
I see stuff yeah if Diane Feinstein
really knew months ago that Brett
Kavanaugh had to say raped somebody
wouldn't she have been under an
obligation to tell federal law
enforcement then why wait until the week
or two before the confirmation vote I'm
Brett Kavanaugh except to scuttle the
boat simply out of out of this kind of
dirty tricks playbook this is really
really dirty stuff Ronan Farrow has a
piece over at The New Yorker in which
he's essentially accusing Brett
Kavanaugh of something more dire or at
least he's or at least he's
substantiating the allegation here's
what Ronan Farrow is writing as well as
Jane Mayer over at The New Yorker
the woman was asked not to be identified
first approached Democratic lawmakers in
July
shortly after Trump nominated Kavanagh
so in other words Democrats knew about
this for months because it is now
September okay so they knew about it in
July August and September they did
nothing about it they didn't refer it to
the FBI they waited until now to take a
allegation that Cavanaugh has apparently
completely denied and throw that into
the public square it's sort of a red
meat thing to stop Bret Cavanaugh's
nomination Democratic lawmakers didn't
do anything about it the allegation
dates back to the early 1980s when
Cavanaugh was a high school student at
Georgetown Prep School in Bethesda
Maryland and the woman attended a nearby
High School in the letter the woman
alleged that during an encounter at a
party Cavanaugh held her down and that
he attempted to force himself on her she
claims in the letter that Cavanaugh and
a classmate of his both of whom had been
drinking turned up music that was
playing in the room to conceal the sound
of her protest and that Cavanaugh
covered her mouth with his hand she was
able to free herself
although the alleged incident took place
decades ago and the three individuals
involved were minors the woman said the
memory had been a source of ongoing
distress for her and that she had sought
psychological treatment as a result in a
statement Cavanaugh said quote I
categorically and unequivocally denied
this allegation I did not do this back
in high school or at any time
Cavanaugh's classmates said of the
woman's allegation I have no
recollection of that and the woman's
declined a request for an interview so
how exactly is Diane Feinstein bringing
this up now again with no evidence other
than this woman's allegation which has
been denied by everyone else who was
there now maybe if she's telling the
truth maybe she is but wouldn't it have
behoove Diane Feinstein to initiate that
investigation say in July when she first
received the information I mean this is
dirty tricks at its very finest it's
dirty trick
all the way down and this is not the
last time this is not the most yeah the
only time the Democrats have tried this
routine they tried the same routine with
Anita Hill during Clarence Thomas's
hearing bringing up allegations that
were thoroughly non-credible for a
variety of reasons about Clarence Thomas
supposedly sexually harassing Anita Hill
talking making jokes about pubic hairs
on coke cans and such and this was
supposed to sink Clarence Thomas they're
trying the same thing here Republicans
should ram through Brett Cavanaugh's
nomination right now the FBI has already
declined to investigate it they
announced that yesterday they have
referred it to the White House for a
background check but that's all because
there's no further evidence that this
actually happened Cavanaugh denies the
allegations and the Democrats are gonna
have to do better than that instead
they're smearing Brett Kavanaugh with an
allegation decades old decades old going
back to when he was 17 years old when he
was a minor and we are supposed to
pretend that this is a legitimate effort
to keep what a serial rapist off the
Supreme Court that's what Democrats are
really doing here this is the dirtiest
of the dirty stuff it's just it's just
gross it's the same thing as when Harry
Reid suggested that MIT Romney had not
paid his taxes they just went out there
and said it and then it turned out the
MIT Romney had in fact paid his taxes
but Harry Reid said you know what we got
what we needed to get done done he
wasn't elected presidents of the United
States
this is gross stuff do you want to write
people think politics is a dirty
disgusting business this is why people
think politics is a dirty and disgusting
business because folks on every side of
the aisle are pretty much willing to do
anything to take down political
opponents and listen I'm on the right
eye I don't think that my side is immune
to this I don't think I'm immune to this
but I think that this is a pretty
egregious example I mean over the last
couple of weeks when we've seen cory
booker doing this routine where he is
spartacus by reviewing documents that
were already revealed or when he saw
Kamala Harris implying that Brett
Kavanaugh had been corruptly discussing
the Muller investigation with members of
president Trump's firm with no evidence
of that whatsoever when you had Sheldon
Whitehouse proclaiming that he didn't
feel subject to the law because Merrick
garland should be on the Supreme Court
and now when you have Dianne Feinstein
dumping into the public record unsourced
allegations of an alleged sexual assault
that took place 35 years ago in order to
stop Brett Kavanaugh his ascension to
the Supreme Court really really gross
stuff and that's not the only dirty
allegation being put out today by
Democrats
in an attempt to smear Republicans we'll
get to another one this one courtesy of
the New York Times in just a second but
first we're talking out a lot of dirty
stuff let's talk about keeping your
teeth clean so you really haven't spent
a lot of time thinking about how to keep
your teeth clean when you go to the
dentist's office they ask you you know
how do you brush for long enough do you
brush twice a day and then you lie and
you say you did but there's no reason
for you to lie instead what you should
be doing is checking out quip quip is an
electric toothbrush that is a fraction
of the cost of bulkier brushes while
still packing just the right amounts of
vibration to help clean your teeth quips
built-in timer helps you clean for the
dentist recommended two minutes with
guiding pulses that remind you when to
switch sides quip subscription plans are
for your health not just convenience
they deliver new brush heads on a
dentist recommended schedule every three
months for just five bucks including
free shipping worldwide quip comes with
a mount that suctions writes your mirror
on sticks to use as a cover for a
hygienic travel wherever you take your
teeth and finally everybody loves quip
they're on Oprah Zola sand in one of
Times best inventions and is there the
first subscription electric toothbrush
accepted by the American Dental
Association so it's a pretty solid
product I have it in my home it's really
great and it does work beautifully it
travels really easily as well quip
starts with just 25 bucks if you go to
get quick comm slash Shapiro right now
you'll get your first refill pack free
with a quip electric toothbrush that is
your first refill pack for free at get
quip comm slash capiro again GE tqu IP
comm slash apparel go check it out right
now get quick comm slash Shapiro and you
get that special deal so that was not
the only dirty attempt by Democrats not
just the Brett Kavanaugh think the White
House by the way has responded
immediately to this White House
spokeswoman Kerry ku Peck said
throughout his confirmation process
judge Cavanaugh has had 65 meetings with
senators including senator Feinstein
said that Feinstein set over sat through
over 30 hours of testimony addressed
over 2,000 questions in a public setting
and additional questions in a
confidential setting not until the eve
of his confirmation has senator
Feinstein or anyone raised the specter
of new information about him
Senator Schumer promised to appo judge
Cavanaugh's nomination with everything I
have it appears he is delivering this
11th hour attempt to delay the
confirmation so it just really grows up
that's not the only gross allegation
today there's a headline at The New York
Times today going after nikki Haley
who's the single most popular Republican
in the country and as I had said before
on this show my spirit animal here is
the headline from The New York Times
State Department spent
fifty two thousand seven hundred and one
dollars on curtains for Nikki Haley's
residence so this is an attempt to paint
nikki Haley as a sort of scott pruett
casually corrupt official who's spending
enormous quantities of cash pear cash in
order to of taxpayer cash in order to
pad her residence hey here's the piece
from the New York Times I'll say you
stopped me when you think you hear the
problem with this New York Times piece
the State Department spent fifty two
thousand seven hundred one dollars last
year buying customized and mechanized
curtains for the picture windows in
Nikki Haley's official residences
ambassador to the UN just as the
department was undergoing deep budget
cuts and then frozen hiring the
residents in a new building on First
Avenue has spectacular views and miss
Haley is the first ambassador to live in
it for decades her predecessors lived in
the Waldorf Astoria Hotel and after the
hotel was purchased by a Chinese
insurance company with the murky
ownership structure the State Department
decided in 2016 to find a new home for
its top New York diplomat because of
security concerns the government leased
the apartment just blocks from the
delegations offices with an option to
buy according to Patrick Kennedy the top
management official at the State
Department during the Obama
administration the full floor penthouse
with handsome hardwood floors covering
large open spaces stretching nearly six
thousand square feet was listed at fifty
eight thousand dollars per month per
month a spokesman for Miss hailey said
plans to buy the curtains were made in
2016 during the Obama administration
Miss hailey had no say in the purchase
he said so the headline is nikki Haley
is responsible for spending fifty three
grand on curtains and then buried in
paragraph four of this piece is the
actual story which is that the Obama
administration outfitted the place for
fifty eight grand on curtains because
they were fully expecting the UN
Ambassador to be a Democrat the Obama
administration was expecting the next
person to occupy that penthouse to be a
Democrat and so they decided to spend
inordinate quantities of cash on
curtains but they're trying to pin it on
nikki Haley anyway so instead it's going
to be that nikki Haley is is somehow
responsible for all of this really a
tremendous smear a really massive smear
from the New York Times again in an
attempt to get top Republican officials
and then you wonder why folks don't
actually trust the media well meanwhile
there were a series of elections in New
York last night and there's
a bizarre split that happened in New
York last night there are a bunch of
very very far left candidates who won in
sort of local races the most prominent
of whom is Julia Salazar a 27 year old
Democratic Socialist who is plagued by
negative news coverage in the final
weeks of her insurgent campaign against
incumbent New York State Senator Martin
Dillon for making misleading statements
about her background she had claimed
that she was the child of Colombian
Jewish immigrants that she had emigrated
she was an illegal immigrant who was
poor from Colombia and Jewish not a
single element of that is true okay
she's not from Colombia she's an
American citizen her parents are
American citizens
she isn't she was not poor she grew up
middle class to upper-middle class
she is not Jewish okay all of this was
false so she's basically a sociopath
just essentially lying about key
elements of her background that didn't
stop people in this New York district
from voting for her for the New York
State Senate because this is a small
district in the middle of North Brooklyn
and as we know Brooklyn is a very very
left area voters in North Brooklyn this
is according to The Huffington Post
which loves Salazar voters in North
Brooklyn on Thursday found her
preferable to Dillon's close ties to the
real estate Lobby Salazar triumphed in
the Democratic primary for the New York
State Senate 18th district seat the
voters may also have been sending a
message of disgust with corruption
scandals that have rocked the state
Senate
Suzan Kang a leader of the New York City
chapter of the Democratic socialists of
America which endorsed Salazar and who's
she's an active dues-paying member of
the organization
she said Julia Salazar's victory is a
testament to how much her policy
platform resonated with the people of
North Brooklyn some of the fastest
gentrifying communities in New York City
her bold platform of fighting for
tenants rights immigrants and transit
riders matters more than this expensive
smear campaign against her and that
shows how important the issues really
are so she she again implied that she
was an immigrant she's not that she was
poor she's not that she graduated from
she said she graduated from Columbia
University she does not have a degree
from Columbia University she said that
she was raised in a Jewish in Jewish
faith that is untrue and I love the New
York The Huffington Post coverage while
these fibs made headlines they're just
fibs
they're just fibs not real lies about
her background they are fibs salazar's
policy platform earned her the
enthusiastic grassroot supports of the
Democratic socialists of America
basically you're talking about one area
of New York that is far left socialist
and keep selecting similar people from
Alexandria
Asya cortez to cynthia nixon but here's
where things get weird that same
district last night that voted for Julia
Salazar voted basically two-to-one for
Andrew Cuomo Andrew Cuomo / Cynthia
Nixon in the Democratic gubernatorial
primary so Cynthia Nixon who was running
to the far left she put out a series of
tweets this morning talking about how
she was very disappointed that so many
people showed up and turned out to vote
for Andrew Cuomo which is a weird thing
for a Democratic Socialist to say
supposedly a power to the people person
she also talked about how true
priorities like banning plastic bags
we're not gonna be taken care of by
Andrew Cuomo can't imagine why she lost
in any case Cynthia Nixon who did win by
the way one third of the vote being her
only qualification for office being
extraordinarily radical on politics
here's what she had to say in the
aftermath of her defeat it is about
offering a vision of the way things
could work if only we have the
leadership and the political courage to
make it a reality this race for the
Democratic nomination may be over but
the fight for the soul of the Democratic
Party is just beginning you know here's
the part that is actually kind of true
about what she's saying and here is
where Republicans run into a bit of a
pickle hey Republicans are betting on
democratic radicalism to save them
they're betting on the fact that the
Democrats have moved very very far and
left to save them in general elections
like 2020 because president Trump's
approval ratings are low because
President Trump will be hit with another
slew of negative headlines regarding
Paul Manafort for example and so the
feeling is the only way that President
Trump cruises to victory in 2020 is
because the Democrats are just bad at
this the Democrats are likely to
nominate somebody who's a far left
radical who's easy to pillory I'm not so
sure that's true because where Cynthia
Nixon is correct is that her agenda is
in fact taking over the Democratic Party
the mainstream Democratic Party people
on the right are counting on the Julia
Salazar in Alexandria Ocasio Cortez's of
the world to take over the party they're
counting on people who are overtly nuts
to take over the route of the Democratic
Party and to a certain extent that's
worked on the grassroots level but I
think that as we rise in democratic
politics they're actually window
the most ridiculous candidates so I'm a
little bit concerned about the fact that
Andrew Cuomo defeated Cynthia Nixon I
was hoping Cynthia Nixon would win
because then we'd actually have the
specter of Cynthia Nixon as New York
Governor we could point to her Andrew
Cuomo is bad enough he's actually bad at
politics but Andrew Cuomo is in fact a
professional politician and I'm gonna
explain why that's important in just one
second but first let's talk about
natural disasters okay right now there's
a natural disaster bearing down on the
east coast of the United States and
there's a solid possibility that a lot
of folks are going to be cut off from
grocery stores from the ability to get
potable water and all the rest and this
is one of the reasons why you really
ought to have some food in your house
that is available in case of emergencies
when there's no power refrigeration
fails stores closed and then what do you
do well I trust my Patriots apply for
dependable food storage you should as
well each person in your household
should have at least a two-week
emergency food supply from my Patriot
supply this week they're offering a
special price of only 75 bucks for a
food kit that contains 92 servings of
breakfasts lunches and dinners call 888
803 1413 or go to my special website
prepare with been calm again that's
eight eight eight eight oh three 14 13
or the special website prepare with been
calm the food lasts up to 25 years in
storage only 75 bucks that includes a
rugged tote order now 888 803 1413 or
prepare with ben's calm folks around the
office have tried the food they say
taste like home cookin and it last for
25 years in storage
888 803 1413 be prepared in case of
disaster prepare with been calm even the
government recommends you ought to have
some sort of food supply in your house
well no reason why it shouldn't be my
Patriot supply good folks who can make
sure that you are equipped in case of
disaster okay so as I say the problem
for the Democrats is the possibility of
unpalatable faces repeating a Democrat
socialist platform people like Julia
Salazar and XL exaggerate Ocasio Cortez
and yes Cynthia Nixon but instead what
has happened is mainstream members of
the Democratic Party have simply moved
to the left to co-opt all of the ideas
of the hardcore left Democratic Party
when Cynthia Nixon says there's a war
inside the Democratic Party the war is
over
and the mainstream Left lost the
mainstream liberals lost the people who
are now in full control of the
Democratic Party are in fact
Democratic socialists who are basically
campaigning that way
even people like Elizabeth Warren he
says she's Pro capitalism yesterday
she came out and she said we should
break up Amazon and we should break up
JPMorgan I'm not sure under what guys
should claim that Amazon is monopoly
that needs to be broken up but all of
this is sort of the populist demagogic
rhetoric you hear on a regular basis
from Democratic socialists all across
the country and folks like beta O'Rourke
who was beloved by the Democratic base
where he's spending his time campaigning
in Washington DC and New York
he is running very close to Ted Cruz in
Texas which is an insane insane thing
ITEX is a very very red state if Pedro
Rock were to pull out that race there's
no question who had immediately turned
around and run for president of the
United States here is better O'Rourke
trying to explain on CBS because this is
what he does he gets all the late-night
slots beta O'Rourke explains that
dreamers should be freed from
deportation by simply granting them full
amnesty and citizenship we don't need
walls we can have smart security
solutions and we can free dreamers from
the fear of deportation by making them
US citizens today so they can contribute
to their maximum capacity to their
potential okay so they don't work again
adopting some of the most radical
elements of the far-left platform he
continued by saying that he would not
actually trade a wall for the DREAM Act
first of all again let me demonstrate
how bias the Left media is when's the
last time Ted Cruz was on The Late Show
the answer is never and they won't even
have apparently people like Norm
Macdonald on The Late Show because Norma
tunnelled is too politically incorrect
but beta O'Rourke who's going to lose
his race to Ted Cruz in all likelihood
that's a guy who they'll have on The
Late Show any any Democrat who has
higher aspirations will get a slot on
The Late Show but the point here is a
little bit broader which is that beta
O'Rourke and mainstream Democrats they
have embraced the radical platform of
people like Julia Salazar and Cynthia
Nixon but they put a more palatable face
on it better or work is better at this
than Julia Salazar right nobody's talked
about Alexandra Ocasio Cortez for
president even if she ran for Senate and
won nobody would be talking about her
for that but bethe O'Rourke is a pretty
smooth polished politician and you can
see that he's effective in pushing
exactly the same message and again you
can see the radicalism of the Democratic
Party at work among mainstream political
figures who feel the need to adopt that
platform Chelsea Clinton is doing the
same thing so Chelsea Clinton is the
child of the guy who said safe legal and
rare should be the standard with regard
bortion here she was yesterday saying it
would be unchristian unchristian to go
back to a time when abortion was illegal
you we just can't go back to that I
think that's unconscionable to me and
also and I'm sure that this will unleash
another wave of hate in my direction but
as a deeply religious person it's also
unchristian
oh it's unchristian now it's unchristian
to prevent the abortion of the unborn as
it's unchristian Wow I mean pretty
pretty amazing stuff there but again the
point here is is the broader point
what's happening is that the Democratic
Socialist platform is now rising up in
the Democratic Party among more
palatable figures including folks like
Andrew Cuomo the reason that Andrew
Cuomo beat Cynthia Nixon is because the
difference between Andrew Cuomo and
Cynthia Nixon was simply not broad
enough to justify voting for an actress
from Sex in the City
over a sitting governor of the state of
New York with a long family history in
New York politics when that happens then
Republicans really should be worried
Republicans should be worried that
Democrats will pick somebody who's a
little bit more publicly palatable but
is mimicking exactly the same messages
of Bernie Sanders it won't be a crazy
old loom bag from Vermont running this
time it'll be somebody who's more
attractive there'll be somebody who's
better at this it'll be somebody who is
who is capable of winning a national
election on a far left platform now
there is some hope left okay and the
hope stands in the fact that a lot of
the a lot of the primary voters on both
sides are more motivated by anger and
revenge than they are by anything
remotely approaching typical politics
and this is why Michael avenatti
I think still provides an outsized
threat on the left I think that
basically the 2020 nomination the
Democratic Party at this point if you
had to give odds you say Elizabeth
Warren is the odds-on favorite Elizabeth
Warren is dangerous because she is
picking up all of the cues from the hard
left Elizabeth Warren used to be kind of
moderate okay back in the day she wrote
books about the two-parent in the two
for the two income trap and we need to
build the middle class by release by
removing some regulation and we need to
restructure our kind of social mores to
to benefit marriage Elizabeth Warren was
not a hardcore radical she's become a
hardcore radical specifically because
she knows that that is what plays with
the Democratic base and while she is a /
silly unappealing candidate in some ways
she can answer the one question that
probably lost Hillary Clinton the
election why do you want to be President
Hillary lost in 2016 because everybody
knew the answer was she just wanted it
because she felt she was owed it
Elizabeth Warren can do the populists
routine far better than Hillary Clinton
can you can see the media already
starting to rally behind Elizabeth
Warren the harvard law professor against
the the rube from queens that's that's
the way they're gonna play this thing so
she's still the front-runner and then
you've got the the sort of insurgent
candidacy of probably Kamala Harris the
Democratic candidate from California
who's his senator out here she's a
terrible senator she was a terrible
Attorney General but she is black and
she is female and she is radical she
checks intersectionality boxes for a lot
of folks on the Left she can
theoretically try out the minority base
in a way Elizabeth Warren may not be
able to and she is good at playing the
prosecutor and then you have the real
dark horse of the race and that dark
horse of the race would be Michael
avenatti so Michael avenatti this is
what Republicans are banking on is that
the Democratic base will be driven so
nuts by Trump they just decide to go get
the angriest guy on television and so
while the rest of the country is and the
elites particularly are laughing and
Michael a vanadis pretensions to glory
they also laughed at Donald Trump's
pretensions to glory all the way until
he was President of the United States
Michael avenatti was on Tucker Carlson
last night and I have to say you know
Tucker I thought did a did a pretty
funny job handling and it was clearly
planned that this thing was gonna be
just a Rock'em Sock'em robots punching
match between tucker carlson and michael
avenatti it benefits have a nodding
it's good for having out it's good for
Tucker too because the ratings are good
and because Tucker is is good with
interviews but avenatti
clearly likes these sorts of situations
he goes into the lion's den and that's
gonna be his pitch his picture is gonna
be I'm the guy who punch his hardest and
you can see exactly how this work last
night so Tucker benefited from the fact
that he was smacking around avenatti
avenatti benefited from the fact he was
punching right back at Tucker this sort
of oppositional politics is Republicans
best hope for somebody like a vanity to
get the nomination so Tucker was
trolling avenatti with all sorts of
hilarious chi runs last night the chyron
writer over at foxnews get to raise the
chyron said things like creepy porn
lawyer to wayne with 20/20 run have an
ID of course is the lawyer first stormy
Daniels
and Tucker takes on creepy porn lawyer
and it was you know pretty glorious
Chiron is there from from Tucker Carlson
avenatti did get into it with Carlson
for Kalima creepy porn where he says why
don't you call Trump the creepy porn
president this is the kind of thing
where avenatti earns points with the
base right he's gonna try and run a hard
left
I fight President Trump campaign and
theoretically he could do more damage
than I think people will give him credit
for why is it that you don't call Donald
Trump the creepy porn president he's the
one that had sex with a four month old
son at home case with my client now
without a condom okay so but you don't
want to acknowledge that you don't want
to acknowledge that acknowledge it okay
do you believe that he had such people
think it's okay if the president lives
settle down okay so it went like this
for avenatti a Vinod he comes out of
this looking good for his base Tucker
comes out of this looking good for his
base I will say the funniest moment of
this interview is when a avenatti asked
Tucker if you watched porn and Tucker
got off a pretty good line here if
you've got that big boy do you have that
bigger problem when's the last time you
saw porn oh you busted me actually many
humiliation porn that's why I watch you
once seeing that no but pretty good line
there from Tucker but again this sort of
oppositional it's funny everybody in the
elites thinks people are watching the
Elizabeth Warren of it all things are
watching the Kamala Harris of it all
more people will watch the clips of
Tucker versus avenatti then we'll see
that Elizabeth Warren has ever said
anything about antitrust this is this is
the best hope for Republicans the best
hope for Republicans is that they
control the Democrats into nominating
somebody like a Michael avenatti the
worst nightmare for Republicans that
somebody who's a credible candidate
comes along who's even remotely likable
and hijacks Cynthia Nixon's platform and
uses that all the way to the presidency
that is that is the worst nightmare for
Republicans and they should take that
under advisement we shouldn't be quite
so sanguine about the possibility the
Democratic moves to the left is
inevitably going to lead to failure on
their part okay we're gonna get to the
mailbag in just a second but first I
want to talk to you about your Second
Amendment rights now as you know I am
sure that you know I'm a proud member of
the u.s. CCA I'm a big Second Amendment
supporter there on emissions
act responsibly armed Americans like you
and me and right now they're smack dab
in the middle of one of their biggest
gun giveaways ever they want to give you
ten free chances to win the gun of your
dreams so which gun is calling your name
maybe it's a classic 1911 or a new Sig
Sauer well get your chance to get it for
free right now simply text win to the
number eight seven two two two and
you'll instantly lock in your 10 free
chances to win again it's that easy just
get your phone out right now and text
win that's WI n 2 8 7 2 2 2 this all
ends next Friday don't miss out it's way
too easy and way too valuable to pass up
and again they want law-abiding citizens
to be armed because that's the basis of
the Second Amendment and the basis of
our freedom texts win - 87 - 2 - right
now that's it
imagine getting 1500 bucks for doing
something that easy ten free chances to
make that dream come true right now text
wins and the number 8 7 2 2 2 + the US
DC is a great organization you should be
supporting anyway they help you out with
educational materials as well as legal
materials in case you have to fire a gun
did somebody God for bed check texts win
- 872 T 2 for your free chances to win
$1500 toward the gun of your dream
pretty awesome and we'll get to the
mailbag as I say in just a second first
we're gonna have to go over to daily
wire.com and subscribe for $9.99 a month
when you do that you got the rest of
this show live the rest of Michael
Knowles's show live the rest mandrel
Clavin shall have the rest of mount
Walsh's show live by the way you get all
of those things when you subscribe plus
it is almost time for our next episode
of the conversation today 5:30 p.m.
Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific I'll be taking
your questions and answering them to the
best of my ability so make the questions
good and we should Krauss will be
hosting and making sure that Michael
Knowles is nowhere in sight thank God as
always this episode will be free for
everyone to watch on Facebook and
YouTube only subscribers can ask the
questions so subscribe to get your
questions answered by yours truly today
5:30 p.m. Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific join
the conversation and again when you get
the annual subscription you got all of
that plus they left us tears hot or cold
tumblr it is spectacular nine nine
dollars a year cheaper than the monthly
subscription go check it out right now
and you got access to our Sunday special
we have announced steven crowder this
week we have a bunch of great sunday
specials coming up they really the guest
list is pretty tremendous so go check
all that out we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
all righty so you know what let's get to
some mailbag here so let's let's jump
right in Jackson says Haven I know there
is a huge hurricane coming for me and I
still say why should the government be
compelled to help me during the storm
well I mean the answer is that the
government should you know putting
yourself in a bad situation doesn't mean
that the government isn't compelled to
try to help you out right I mean if you
if you walk through a heavily
crime-ridden neighborhood in the middle
of the night and get mugged the police
are still supposed to show up if you
stay in an area where you're not
supposed to be the the FEMA rescuers are
still supposed to show up I do think
that you ought to bear a higher
financial cost for doing that like I
think that you should actually have to
pay more money for doing that the
government should find people for
staying in areas where they are expected
not to pick up the cost even if their
house gets flooded by water John says
honorable Chief Justice Shapiro many
years from now how do you think this era
of politics from roughly 2012 to today
and on will be taught in education do
you think there's any chance the
left-leaning education systems will fail
at some point and change perspective
what is the most significant example you
can think of where history is taught and
it completely wrong and twisted manner
to American students thanks to you and
Daily wire for the continued inspiration
well the Howard Zinn version of history
is taught routinely in the United States
his book a people's history of the
United States has sold over 2 million
copies
basically attributing every individual
evil to America and every individual
good to the world civilization at large
this is something left loves to do
slavery uniquely American sexism
uniquely American racism uniquely
American landing man on the moon world
achievement and in World War 2 world
achievement ending sexism ending slavery
ending racism world achievements all of
that is absolute nonsense and there's no
basis for that whatsoever as far as how
do i think this year of politics will be
taught well I think if people regain
sanity they're gonna look at 2012 is the
election that broke the country I think
2012 really made the country worse in a
variety of what like imagine right now
if Mitt Romney were in his second term
or he drummed in running for reelection
in 2020 as opposed to Hillary Clinton
versus Donald Trump you think the
country might be better in a lot of ways
I think the country would be a lot
better in a lot of ways if Obama had not
won a second term in 2012 and used his
identity politics in order
- in order to seize victory I think that
would have been very I think that
election was horrible for the country I
think it trolled the right into near
insanity and I think that in turn has
trolled the left into near insanity it
has polarized politics in dramatic ways
2008 didn't break the country but I
think 2012 really did serious damage to
the country Adam says I know there's a
general saying about men falling in love
or marrying a woman similar to their
mothers and women with their fathers do
you think there's truth to that is r
wife anything like your own mother and
how thanks for the infinite insight well
yeah I mean I think that you are driven
to imitate people that you love and if
you are if you like your mom then you're
gonna look for somebody who is like your
mom in a lot of ways so the ways that my
wife is like my mom they they have it's
always funny every so often there will
be some weird commonality between my mom
and my wife and we'll all just start
laughing about it so my wife has a
tendency to mix up movies in the most
bizarre ways my mom is the same thing my
wife will forget about the plot of
movies extraordinarily quickly in the
same way that my mom will they have a
lot of commonalities in sort of weird
quirky ways um they're very they're
similarly practical my mom is career
woman my wife is a career woman and
because I admire my mom a lot I would
say that my wife is similar my mom and
those ways there are ways in which my
wife is different there are things about
my mom that you know I like less than I
like about my wife and I looked
specifically for ways in which my wife
would be different from my mom I think
that one of the things that can help you
pick a good spouse is making a serious
objective analysis of what you liked and
disliked about your parents because that
allows you to get a little bit of
distance instead of sort of falling
instinctually into the pattern of
marrying somebody who's exactly like
your parents your parents are models for
your life so of course you're gonna
marry somebody who seems to be like your
parents in a lot of ways but trying to
analyze what it is that drives you nuts
about your parents is also a good way to
avoid marrying somebody who exhibits
those same characteristics andrew says
hey Ben I'm a Spanish professor and I
want students to join my major but I
also want my students to make money
after college what should the role of
humanities in college related to be
related to yesterday's comments well
listen i think that the humanities
education was originally designed to
inculcate things like virtue and
american values in a certain level of
background knowledge about your
civilization but since we no longer do
that obviously things should be
job-related now I think that being a
Spanish major is actually pretty useful
I live in the state of California well
last night my wife and I spent half an
with rosetta stone specifically because
we're trying to learn spanish so yeah I
think that your major is actually a
useful major when it comes to English
majors however it seems to me that the
only thing that trains you to be as an
English teacher or an English professor
because the number of successful writers
in the United States is extraordinarily
low as a percentage that doesn't mean
people shouldn't major in English or
enjoy English I love English I took a
lot of English courses in college I
enjoyed them tremendously but I think
that if you are looking at the job of a
college you have to determine what is
the risk reward benefit you know what is
it what what is the opportunity cost if
you could have measured in something
that was gonna earn you more money what
if that would that have been the best
possible use of your time as opposed to
majoring in something that you maybe
enjoyed more College has essentially
become a sorting mechanism for grad
school
that's all colleges at this point it
doesn't almost matter where you went to
college who matters a lot more where he
went to grad school it doesn't matter
that much I went to UCLA matters a lot
more I went to Harvard Law School cuz
Harvard Law prepared me for an actual
job
Blake's has been when planning for a
marriage proposal is it more important
to get debt and finances in order first
or is there more or less that I should
consider well I think that it is
important to be able to support your
family obviously but I think that the
first thing that you should be
considering is whether you are capable
of living a responsible lifestyle
generally and treating your wife or
husband with the most appropriate level
of respect and dignity necessary
treating them as an individual human
being not as a tool for gratification of
your emotional desires that is the
biggest thing constantly working on
yourself is what makes marriage better
constantly working on your spouse is
what makes a marriage worse you want
them you want to ruin your marriage you
wanna run your relationship nitpick your
spouse but make sure by the way that you
find a spouse who is capable of changing
when when they are called on something
that is worthy of changed rachel says
hey Ben why is it called single payer
health care when everyone pays thanks
Rachel well the reason is because the
single payer is the government but it's
really just a euphemism it makes it
sound better than nationalized health
care which is what single-payer is it
was really funny Cynthia Nixon said
earlier today that we need a Democratic
Party that embraces single-payer health
care is like every major Democratic
candidate has now embraced the Medicare
for all plan now there's some folks who
I respect in health care policy you say
well embracing Medicare for all doesn't
necessarily mean it's single-payer no it
means it's the first step toward
single-payer because once you have a
government option the government can
simply under
everybody else the government does not
cost you anything why would you buy
private supplemental insurance if the
government is going to cover it anyway
maybe you do that but the government is
then going to have to restrict your
access to that insurance in order to
prevent every doctor from simply taking
that insurance and rejecting Medicare so
heavily regulating creating a public
option does create an enormous number of
problems in the private market and in
fact does lead more toward a
single-payer system although obviously
there are hybrid systems like Australia
where a huge number of people buy
supplemental health insurance - all says
hey Ben could you explain how evolution
is compatible with creationism thanks
love the show fan from hungry there's a
great book by a Gerald Schroder called
Genesis in the Big Bang that's really
worth reading I've recommended it many
times basically the idea of evolution
being consonant with creationism is
there is a force that stands behind
evolution God has to use a mechanism
that mechanism is evolution I honestly
find it puzzling that folks have a very
tough time rectifying the balance
between the two I understand why folks
by the way would want to take the Bible
literally because they say if you're
gonna take this part metaphorically and
you take this part literally how do we
know what's metaphorical and what's
literal and the answer to that is sort
of the Thomas Aquinas answer which is
what science tells us is also the
presence of God in the universe so
science and the Bible cannot be in
conflict
you're either misinterpreting the Bible
or you're getting the science wrong one
of the two has to be wrong if you're a
true Jew or Christian but creationism is
fully consonant with the idea of
evolution because again the order of
creation suggests that God created
living material and then he created
plants and then he created in animals
and then he created and then he created
human beings there's there's nothing
there that says by what mechanism God
actually did all of that Stephen says -
who's your favorite founding father
thanks and I love the show
you'd have to hose it you'd have to say
Washington just cuz he's the greatest
man in American history and this is a
person who was capable of uniting a
country that was divided about virtually
every issue and then seeding power as
soon as he could do so legally it's an
amazing thing the amount of the the
confidence that you have to have to say
I'm walking away from power now I'm
gonna hand it to somebody who I don't
necessarily even trust like John Adams
and I'm gonna hand it to that guy and
just walk
way it's pretty tremendous house has
been what legal authority do public
universities have to deny students their
second Amendment rights well public
universities from my understanding have
the same authority as local cities and
and local and and localities and
counties which is they can make
regulations that that prevail on their
particular swath of territory as long as
those don't violate the Constitution
with regard to the second amendment so
that really hasn't been litigated too
much you haven't seen a lot of cases
with regard to the Second Amendment
frankly but let's say the state of Texas
were to pass a law saying that the that
conceal and carry is the law of the land
and then the University of Texas said no
it's hard to see how that could trump
the state law of Texas actually let's
see finn says dear lord vader how do you
think we should pay for the border wall
i think we should just take all the
money we would spend on straws and use
that to build the wall well i mean
frankly i think that we have the money
to pay for the border wall it is in
pretty much every attempted defense
appropriations bill so I think the
border wall is bln oh by the way I don't
I mean I'm in favor of a border wall do
I think it's the chief mechanism for
curbing illegal immigration I don't I
think the chief method for curbing
illegal immigration is deportation and
that needs to rise with regard
specifically to people who have
overstayed their visas but it is a
serious problem that we have have
avoided paying our Freight on a variety
of issues in the border wall included
Mexico is not gonna pay for it by the
way that's just that's only Jay says hi
Ben I'm a programmer in Seattle
Washington I'm growing increasingly
fearful of the homeless problem there's
got much worse in the past years with
tents popping up all over the place we
had multiple brush fires that have been
started along i-5 human feces literally
lining the sidewalks trash is everywhere
what do you think is the source of this
recent uptick in homelessness and what
do you think local governments can do to
solve the issue well the long term cause
of homelessness is the dramatic rise of
drug use and mental illness on our
streets so it used to be that folks were
forcibly institutionalized when they
were a danger to themselves or others
and living on the street in mentally ill
State is not actually a healthy thing
but the left has basically decided that
you have the freedom to live on the
street and has promulgated the lie that
most of the people living on the street
are people who are simply victims of
economic circumstance which is not true
the huge swath of the folks who are
living on the streets have serious
mental illness ends or our drug addicts
and have serious problems beyond just
they're poor they're homeless shelters
available and a lot of these folks are
not staying at homeless shelters because
they want to live outdoors we don't have
a right to do that the way to fix the
homeless problem is to jail people if
they if they are defecating on public
land it is - it is to take away the
stuff that they have on the street and
put them in jail Rudy Giuliani did this
with Times Square he cleaned up Times
Square it is only the localities have
decided that they're not going to do
anything about the homeless problem the
homeless problem remains a major problem
in cities like Los Angeles where we have
60,000 homeless people last count and
Seattle where the attempts to build tent
cities that are reminiscent of
Hoovervilles has continued unabated for
the past several years turning the
Emerald City a worse shade of poop brown
lisa has been as a former left-leaning
millennial turned right-leaning
do you think Millennials over time will
become more conservative or remain the
same Thanks well I think that the
evidence is that they will turn more
right-leaning but the question is how
many and right now there's a pretty
durable polarization in American
politics of the myth that a bunch of
people who are on the Left when they're
18 are gonna be on the right by the time
they're 40 I don't think that's true
fewer of them are getting married fewer
of them are having children most of them
are pretty ensconced in a media world
that suggests that all conservatives are
racist sexist bigoted homophobes this is
why I'm you know deeply troubled by
President Trump's rhetoric a lot of the
time I think he's driving away future
generations from the Republican Party
and the polls bear out my point of view
on this I don't think that this is a
simple this is as simple as people get
older they pay taxes and they turn
Republican I just I don't think that's
the case unfortunately culture wars seem
to matter a lot more than economic ones
okay final question here let's see this
is kind of an interesting one let's see
hi Ben this from Sonia I love your show
it's basically part of my lunch routine
at this point not really politics but I
wanted to ask for your opinion on purely
cosmetic surgery I don't have any real
convictions one way or the other
although I do lean heavily against them
following the whole their unnatural and
a waste argument this is an issue
specifically in my case mostly because I
have parents have been hounding me for
about a year to get some sort of nose
job I know a lot of people from my
ethnicity end up getting one at some
point
thanks persons Armenian I guess the
things
and love the show and they say they're
Armenian that's not me making a racial
slur at this point the money isn't a
factor in the decision the only thing
keeping this from happening is me thanks
men again love the show so I actually
like the Jewish perspective on this
which is that you should not seek
optional surgery you know optional
surgery puts you at risk and seems
ungrateful for you know what it is that
God gave you unless you can't get a
off so in the Jewish world that means
that unless it's like preventing you
from getting married if it's actually
providing you significant hardship in
your life to have your nose shape the
way it is then it seems to me not
abnormal to go get a nose job that I
don't think that's the end of the world
by any stretch of the imagination there
there are cases in which plastic surgery
that is optional I think is is still
fully warranted so for example there are
many women who after they have a double
mastectomy for breast cancer will have
breast reconstruction surgery they don't
have to do it for health reasons they
want to do because it makes them feel
better it makes them feel more beautiful
I don't see any problem with that at all
however if you're just a dude and you
want to like have washboard abs you just
go get liposuction because you're vain
that seems to me like a waste and a bit
of foolishness okay time for some things
I like and then we'll get to a thing
that I hate so things that I like today
we are doing some more Brad Meltzer book
so Brad Meltzer has this great series of
children's books they're just terrific
my daughter loves them the latest in the
series I am Neil Armstrong in which
presumably Neil Armstrong does indeed
plant a flag on the moon I'm like in
first man these books are great they
basically portray all of these
characters as kind of kid versions of
themselves and they tell their whole
story there's one about Abraham Lincoln
that's great there's one about George
Washington that's just terrific my
daughter loves these books loves them
and the illustrations by christian by
christopher le appleís are really
tremendous really this is this is it you
wonder how to educate your kids this is
a great way to educate your kids there's
a lot of great stuff in these books and
Brad who I've interviewed on the program
before does a great job with them okay
time for a couple of things that I hate
okay so thing number one that I hate so
yes last night Fox 4 put out this sweet
Fox in Dallas put out this sweet
developing search warrant marijuana
found in Botham genes apartment after
deadly shooting and this tweet rightly
got ratio to the skies Botham gene if
you missed it I discussed it a couple of
days ago Bothan gene is a black fella
lived in Dallas I guess he was a rep for
a pharmaceutical company or something I
can't remember what his job was
insurance maybe and he was in his own
apartment a police officer who lived
downstairs walked into his apartment she
thought it was her own apartment this is
her case and then she saw a black guy
hulking around her apartment and shot
him I mean that's that's basically what
she says
does that sound racial maybe does it
sound really bad in any case absolutely
okay and there is no excuse for walking
into someone else's apartment and
shooting them to death okay that's what
happened with this lady because she's a
cop it seems like the Police Department
is doing its damnedest to try and
justify the shooting and so they've now
issued a search warrant against his
apartment and they found pot there if
you think that being shot in your own
apartment car if this guy had a hydro
lab in his apartment I don't care if he
was baking crystal meth in his apartment
if he was in his apartment and he wasn't
doing anything and when I say he wasn't
doing anything and he wasn't threatening
anyone else you cannot go into his
apartment and shoot him particularly if
there's not a search warrant like it's
one thing if they ask bacon crystal meth
in his apartment and the cops come to
raid his apartment and he resists arrest
in some way he goes for the cops gonna
get shot that's that's one thing but if
he's literally just in his apartment
making some tea and in the other room he
was baking crystal meth and you made a
mistake and you wandered into his
apartment and shot him and oh look it
just happens to me he's got crystal meth
in the bathtub what exactly does that
have to do with the shooting in the
marijuana certainly has nothing so what
so about hell what like really what
would this be the headline back in you
know 1928 during Prohibition if somebody
accidentally got shot in their apartment
ooh bottle of gin found on the
nightstand so so what this idea that
that police officers have to be given
this above and beyond level of exemption
for behavior that is clearly criminal
seems to me absolutely absurd and that
needs to stop as soon as possible you
want to restore trust between the police
and and the community one of the ways to
do that is to actually prosecute police
when they do bad things and not to try
and obscure these facts with with
silliness about marijuana being found in
an apartment okay other things that I
hate so CNN's John Avlon is is doing one
of the things that the left loves to do
which is suggesting that presidential
policy is going to lead to people dying
and so far we haven't really had a lot
of evidence that people die because of
global warming what we have seen is
evident
that global warming may be happening
over a period of time that human impact
has some effect on the on the
environment that even if you make the
case that storms are more severe because
of this that doesn't necessarily link
the death toll to the severity of the
storm right there are a lot of
intervening factors like how well is the
town built in people evacuate right
there are a lot of things that are that
are linked to that but when we are now
saying from CNN is the attempt to use
this current hurricane Florence that is
threatening the East Coast as a as a
club against Trump so now if John Avalon
on CNN claiming that President Trump's
policies could lead to 80,000 excess
deaths per decade dismantling the clean
power plan and opening nearly all our
course coastline to offshore drilling
it's so bad that according to two
Harvard scientists Trump's environmental
policies could lead to an additional
80,000 unnecessary deaths every decade
okay why what like I'm so glad that they
have now linked policies to death so how
many excess deaths would Affordable Care
Act have led to based on shortages in in
doctors how many excess deaths have been
created by the National Health Service
how many access that like all of these
calculations are based on the kind of
modeling that you do and the modeling
doesn't take into account market changes
it doesn't take into account migration
it doesn't take into account future
technological changes it's very easy to
say that your the policies of your
opponent are going to cause death but
that seems like an extreme case now
that's pretty extreme if you actually
want to make the case against President
Trump's policies instead of saying it's
gonna cause death which is just
off-putting in some way say president
Trump's policies are irresponsible with
regards to the environments and they are
going to cause an upsurge in bad weather
that has significant impact on the
economy and that may result in
additional danger to populations if for
example storms get worse don't try and
forecast how many people gonna die
because Trump didn't pick up an Obama or
a regulation it's just it's silly towns
and it's an exaggeration most people can
detect okay we'll be back here on Monday
with all of the latest i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing